wie einiges von ihnen auch hatte ich am
sonntag die gelegenheit mit dem
ukrainischen ministerpräsidenten dennis
schmidt leid zu sprechen und er hat mir
noch einmal
geschildert dass in sehr eindringlichen
worten was zurzeit das ergebnis dieses
angriffskrieges los ganz auf die ukraine
ist und frau mohammed ali man müsse mit
russland jetzt mal in verhandlungen
treten man müsste mit denen mal reden
wissen sie was alle telefone sind immer
offen aber die wahrheit ist russland
will genau das was gerade passiert auch
mit dem menschen der ukraine das ist
kein versehen russischer politik es ist
absicht russischer politik dass menschen
in der ukraine steht meine damen und
herren das ist das durch fälligkeit
diesen typ das ist das durch pelikan
tischen steht von methan- und
wir spüren die finanziellen auswirkungen
ich komme darauf gleich zu sprechen
während in der ukraine jeden tag
menschen sterben ihr zuhause verlieren
oder das land verlassen müssen
ich habe
ministerpräsident michael wie viele von
ihnen auch in diesen gesprächen die
solidarität auch der bundesrepublik
deutschland noch einmal zum ausdruck
gebracht und zur einordnung dessen was
passiert
russland wladimir putin führt einen
physischen krieg gegen die menschen in
der ukraine aber er führt eben auch ein
krieg mit nahrungsmitteln und mit
energie gegen die gesamte welt und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass der
westen weiter zusammen steht meine damen
und herren deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass die nato derzeit gestärkt wird
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir auch
mit unseren transatlantischen freunden
in diesen tagen auch was das thema
waffenlieferung betrifft auch was das
thema finanzielle unterstützung der
ukraine betrifft zusammenstehen der
zusammenhalt der westlichen
staatengemeinschaft ist die ganz
zentrale antwort in diesen schwierigen
tagen für die gesamte welt liebe
kollegen
von nicht will als erstes auf das thema
was in vielen reden heute morgen schon
natürlich unterstrichen worden ist
nämlich die energieversorgung zu
sprechen kommen die oberste prämisse in
den nächsten monaten ist die preise an
den energiemärkten müssen sinken diese
preise meine damen und herren das muss
man sehr klar aussprechen sind für
niemanden derzeit zu tragen nicht für
die privaten haushalte in deutschland
nicht für die unternehmen nicht nur für
die energieunternehmen in der
energieintensiven unternehmen nicht zu
tragen sondern selbst der einzelhändler
um die ecke kann sich 20 fach höhere
stromkosten schlicht und einfach nicht
leisten aktuell ist es etwa das
zehnfache aber selbst das führt
natürlich zu katastrophalen entwicklung
im gerade in mittelständischen
unternehmen meine damen und herren ja
das ist die ausgangssituation und herr
kollege merz ich fand ihre aussage sehr
interessant weil wir ja auch darüber
sprechen müssen um für die zukunft zu
lernen was in den letzten jahren
passiert ist sie haben gesagt diese
regierung trägt nicht allein die
verantwortung für die abhängigkeit
russlands
wissen sie was diese bundesregierung
stellt sich der verantwortung die
verantwortung in jedem fall trägt diese
bundesregierung und nicht aber sie ist
gebet um jetzt verantwortung zu
übernehmen und das tun wir liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
es ist die abhängigkeit russlands vom
erdgas und das ist da keine leichten
antworten gibt haben die reden heute
morgen deutlich gesagt herr merz ich
will auch daran erinnert was sie am 10
märz diesen jahres gesagt haben sie
waren der erste politiker aus der
unionsfraktion der gesagt hat man muss
die
erdgaslieferung die energielieferungen
aus russland sofort einstellen das ist
das herz was sie am 10 märz gesagt hat
das ist das was sie anziehen märz
niemand ist glücklich über diese
abhängigkeit ist eine ökonomische
katastrophe und auch geopolitisch zu uns
eine herausforderung aber herr mehr
zubereiten könnte zu dieser einfachen
antworten gibt es nicht weder das
einstellen der erdgaslieferung noch
jetzt irgendwelche deckel ich komme mir
darauf gleich zu sprechen sind die
perfekte antwort diese bundesregierung
ich wiederhole es stellt sich dieser
verantwortung die vorgängerregierung
verursacht haben liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
und jetzt will ich sagen was wir tun sie
mir die gasanlage viel gesprochen wir
werden jetzt die mehrwertsteuer auf
diese gas umlage noch einmal senken und
die zielgerichtete
ausrichten meine damen und herren denn
es ist natürlich für viele kunden für
viele unternehmen geradezu ein
überraschen sie wussten bisher gar nicht
von wem der lieferant das erdgas bezogen
hat ist es doch niemand verantwortlich
zu machen kein unternehmen kann
mittelständler das ja russisches erdgas
über seinen versorger bezogen hat und
jetzt in dramatische preissteigerungen
kommt deswegen brauchen wir dort eine
umlage das ist das thema gasmarkt habe
ich komme auf den strommarkt zu sprechen
der hier auch viel besprochen worden ist
meine damen und herren es
ist kein geheimnis dass auch in der
frage der weiternutzung der kernenergie
meine parteien auffassung dazu hat auch
was die drei bestehenden kernkraftwerke
betrifft aber genauso richtig ist es
dass wir jetzt an diesem strommarkt
etwas tun und deswegen ist die
entscheidung des koalitionsausschusses
sich für eines strompreis bremse nicht
nur einzusetzen auf europäischer ebene
sondern gegebenenfalls
national auf diesen schritt zu gehen das
bestehende system der regel umlage zu
nutzen damit die strompreise in
deutschland für alle menschen für alle
unternehmen nach unten gehen das ist die
richtige antwort in dieser krise auch
wenn sie ordnungspolitisch nicht leicht
ist das sage ich ganz offen aber es ist
die richtige antwort in dieser krise
dass die strompreise so runter gehen
meine damen und herren unendlich richtig
als die knallige märkte und an die
unternehmen in deutschland
und herr merz was schlagen sie denn vor
den bug problembeschreibung auch die
abhängigkeit von russland da sind wir
einer meinung aber was haben sie denn
vorgeschlagen für den strommarkt haben
sie sehr konkret vorgeschlagen denn sie
waren ja verzug spitze ich habe mich
gefragt beim lesen des papiers ob es
bisweilen auch mit der die lüfter um
zusammen ging sie haben vorgeschlagen
für den strommarkt das spanische modell
sie sagen dort ein gaspreis deckel an
der stelle und erdgas soll aus dem
strommarkt herausgenommen werden wir
wissen übrigens gar wir sehen gerade was
in spanien passiert in spanien
finanzieren die spanischen
steuerzahlerin steuerzahler gerade den
stromexport nach frankreich meine damen
und herren um den sturm an der stelle
billiger zu machen das kann doch kein
modell für deutschland sein dass unsere
steuerzahler dann am ende des tages
subventionierten strom bezahlen und das
über den bundeshaushalt herr merz das
ist keine option für deutschland die
strompreis bremse ist die richtige
antwort und deswegen hat die
bundesregierung diese auch getroffen
zweitens seien gasmarkt beim gas markt
schlagen sie in ihrem papier von der
zugspitze vor einen gaspreis deckel
wissen sie werden gerade verteidigt hat
vor mohammed ali von der linkspartei
also sie sagen am besten soll das über
den bundeshaushalt geregelt werden der
bundeshaushalt wird dann die differenz
dieses deckels und vergleich zum
marktpreis tragen meine damen und herren
mit ihren vorschlägen suggerieren sie
eine ist nämlich dass die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler die
gestiegenen energiepreise decken können
ich sagen aller kleid ja wir werden an
diesen märkten veränderung vornehmen
aber ein spurt zur weiter zu der staat
die gemeinschaft der steuerzahlerinnen
steuerzahler der kann diese
energiepreise nicht einfach schultern
das würde die staatliche gemeinschaft in
deutschland überfordern diese wahrheit
muss man aussprechen alles andere herrn
merz ist eine illusion ich will das
deutlich an dieser stelle sagen liebe
kollegen
und ich hab's schon gesagt putin hat
diese krise ausgelöst aber
wir wissen doch alle dass der reformstau
in diesem land angesichts dieser krise
wie unter einem brennglas deutlich wird
meine damen und herren deutschland ist
bei der digitalisierung hinterher wir
sind beim klimaschutz hinterher wir
haben viel geld dafür ausgegeben den
letzten jahrzehnten aber wenig erreicht
am ende des tages die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der bundesrepublik
deutschland ist gefährdet wegen zu
starker abhängigkeiten es muss mal
gesagt werden wir sind in deutschland in
den letzten zwei jahrzehnten aus vielen
dingen ausgestiegen meine damen und
herren aus vielen technologien
ausgestiegen aber wir hätten zum
gleichen zeitpunkt mit aller macht auch
in neue technologien einsteigen müssen
meine damen und herren der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie ist nicht in dem
maße vorangekommen aber vor allen dingen
der ausbau das eher konventionelle
energie hätte ersetzen können meine
damen und herren wo war denn der einsatz
seiner zeit für den ausbau der
stromnetze wo war denn da einsatz seiner
zeit für die grundlastfähigkeit auch
erneuerbaren energien das muss doch die
zukunft zwar ein co2 neutrales aber
gleichzeitig trat verfahren die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
meine damen und herren da sind die
fehler gemacht worden für sieben
erneuerbare anzeigenblatt und
landschaftsbild vor uns sind die
erneuerbaren die wirtschaftliche
grundlage der zukunft der bundesrepublik
deutschland die wir kollegen kollegen
noch einmal deutlich zu sagen
und ich komme zu dem neben den dingen
die wir an den märkten tun müssen ich
habe das unterstrichen ich komme zum
entlastungspaket zum dritten
entlastungspaket denen das der
koalitionsausschuss am wochenende
erarbeitet hat als
erstes der inflationsausgleich für die
arbeitenden menschen in diesem land
steht an oberster stelle in diesem paket
und das richtigerweise und auch da muss
ich noch einmal auf das eingehen was sie
lieber herr kollege merz in ihrer rede
gerade gesagt haben sie haben gerade
richtung der bundesregierung behauptet
das stünde ja eben gesetz das würde
sozusagen ja eh automatisch also wir
hätten gesetzestext aufgeschrieben ich
würde ganz gerne eine wette eingehen ich
möchte den paragrafen
einkommensteuergesetz gerne sehen herr
merz wo das was sie behauptet haben drin
steht die wahrheit ist doch die union
hatte nie den mut den abbau der kalten
progression in der einkommensteuer
gesetze schreiben die wahrheit ist das
was ihr behauptet ist schlicht falsch ja
andere europäische länder machen das
deutschland macht es bedauerlicherweise
bisher nicht und weil das nicht der fall
ist wird diese ampel point zu uns die
hart arbeitende mitte in deutschland
entlasten ein ganz wichtiges signal des
koalitionsausschusses wie ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir werden natürlich auch um
diejenigen kümmern die nicht im
arbeitsleben sind um die rentnerinnen
und rentner auch die menschen in
ausbildung um die studierende und
studierende mit einer weiteren energie
pauschalen wir werden das kindergeld
erhöhen wir werden die home office
pauschal im steuerrecht entfristen wir
senken die umsatzsteuer auf gas ich
erwähnte ist von wir setzen den co2
preis wie erhöhung zum ersten januar aus
damit die menschen und unternehmen nicht
zusätzlich belastet werden die
steuerliche absetzbarkeit der
rentenbeiträge das thema
doppelbesteuerung von unionsgeführten
bundesregierung nie gelöst
diese bundesregierung lösen meine damen
und herren und es wird ein bundesweites
nahverkehrsticket geben und da ist ja
manche bundesländer in deutschland gibt
in denen die union entweder den
ministerpräsident gestellt oder mit in
der bundesregierung ist habe ich
folgenden appell für sie anstatt hier
hin und her zu reden unterstützen sie
den verkehrsminister volker wissing bei
diesem revolutionären vorhaben ein
digitales deutschland ticket bundesweit
anzubieten da müssen die länder jetzt
über ihren schatten springen wer eine
revolution für unseren öffentlichen
personennahverkehr genau das zu tun
meine damen und herren
also es sind die familien der mitte aber
auch diejenigen die es schwer haben die
von diesen dritten entlastungspaket
entsprechend profitieren meine damen und
herren jetzt habe ich mir auch an der
stelle noch mal angeschaut was auf der
zugspitze so passiert ist und was in den
letzten tagen gesagt worden ist sagt ja
das waren richtige schritte ich
anerkenne dass das sie sagen auch
entlastung kalte progression und manches
mehr sind richtige schritte den wir als
regierungskoalition gehen ich habe mir
angeschaut was wir fordern sie haben es
eben hier nochmal wiederholt das untere
drittel der einkommen eine pauschale von
1000 euro das macht etwa 16 milliarden
euro für den bundeshaushalt für jedes
kind einmal noch mal 1000 euro das sind
etwa fünf milliarden für den
bundeshaushalt und der vorgeschlagene
gaspreis decke meine damen und herren
der wird etwa 38 milliarden euro für den
bundeshaushalt machen ich will mich ich
will mich nicht auf den euro festlegen
meine damen und herren ich habe das aber
mal zusammengerechnet was sie
offensichtlich nicht getan haben wir
reden hier über 50 milliarden euro
zusätzliche belastung für den etat für
den bundeshaushalt meine damen und
herren ich frage wer soll das bezahlen
sie fordern einen gaspreis deckel
anstelle einer umlage ich frage wer soll
das bezahlen
sie fordern eine subventionierung der
gasverstromung als unionsfraktion
anstelle der strompreis bremse ich frage
wer soll das bezahlen meine damen und
herren der gaspreis deckel wo sie
eigentlich sind mit der linkspartei
sollte aus dem haushalt finanziert
werden aber die sind wenigstens so
ehrlich und sagen dass sie die
schuldenbremse abschaffen wollen meine
damen und herren die stabilität unseres
landes ist in diesen tagen gefragt und
alles das will ich zum schluss sagen
darf auf gar keinen fall passieren indem
wir den bundeshaushalt selber
überfordern indem wir eine expansive
geldpolitik und ausgabepolitik am ende
des tages machen es darf auf gar keinen
fall passieren dass wir die inflation
durch den haushalt zusätzlich anreize
und frau präsidentin ich komme jetzt zum
schluss und will noch eine anmerkung
machen in aller kürze und da habe ich
mir angeschaut was sie noch vorschlagen
sie schlagen vor eine abwrackprämie für
haushaltsgeräte das klingt ja jetzt erst
mal nett aber ich frage mich
welcher ökonom in der gesamten welt ist
zurzeit auf der empfehlung dass er sagt
wir müssten in zeiten der inflation
nachfrage politik zu machen anstatt
angebotspolitik ich habe vorhin erwähnt
was die bundesregierung alles macht aber
mit verlaub herr merz ökonomisch sind
jedoch gerade auf der vierspurigen uhr
mitlaufen sie da falsch in zeiten der
inflation in zeiten der inflation muss
man doch angebotspolitik machen planungs
beschleunigungen wir digitalstrategie
die giga bcg damit netze die bildung
investitionen in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur mehr
freihandelsabkommen und mehr
einwanderung in den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt meine damen und herren
ökonomisch und ich hätte fast nicht mehr
geglaubt dass ich das jemals aussprechen
werden ökonomisch sind so manche
jungsozialisten in der spd zurzeit
marktwirtschaft wächst als die
unionsfraktion im deutschen bundestag
ich danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]